by now you'll probably have heard of the
Wagner group that shadowy group of
mercenaries fighting alongside Russian
forces in Ukraine but like me you
probably don't know much about their
leader you have any pregosian although
you may well have seen footage of him
recruiting soldiers from inmates in a
Russian prison
one of its latest videos was published
on telegram the Russian founded social
medium which has proved a hotbed for
cranks and conspiracy theorists it's
filmed in back moot a city in the east
of Ukraine which has seen some of the
war's worst fighting
these guys here are Wagner men who have
died today he says the blood is fresh
the camera then turns to show tens of
bodies lying on the ground precaution
angrily addresses the camera again
now listen to me you
these are someone's father and someone's
son
and those who are not giving us any
ammunition will be in Hell munching on
their insights
we have a 70 shortage of ammunition
progression then directly addresses the
Russian defense minister and the head of
Russia's Armed Forces
Where is the ammunition
now understandably the international
media were quick to pick up on those
remarks after all it is not often you
see such language directed at those so
close to Vladimir Putin
so just who is yevgeny pregosian a man
who at least at one time was so close to
the Kremlin he was known as Putin's chef
I'm Neil Patterson and this is this guy
News Daily
well let's speak to a couple of
academics who know an awful lot about
Russia and and let's start with
pregosian himself he was born in Saint
Petersburg which is the same town that
Vladimir Putin
very important detail because a Vladimir
Putin a new guinea pig ocean have known
each other for a very long time Samantha
debender is associate Phil at the Royal
Institute of international Affairs
krugersen is a former con man he was a
thug he was put in prison in the 1980s
for basically assaulting a woman in the
streets he spent quite a number of years
in the Soviet Union's Penitentiary
system and this is something that's very
visible even today when he records
videos he often uses prison slang
and when you when you consider the fact
that a lot of the Russian population has
passed through the prisoners you can
understand the appeal that this has he
then left prison just as pureestroika
and glasnos were happening in the Soviet
Union well that of course was the period
in the 90s when Russia was was opening
up to the world under President
Gorbachev he very quickly got on to the
private property private Enterprise
bandwagon and ended up being a hot dog
seller and this is where things become
very mysterious because he he
transformed himself from hot dog seller
to restaurant her for the Grand and
great a new post-soviet Russian Elite
now one thing that's important to
understand in the Soviet Union in indeed
in the dying days when private
Enterprise was allowed you could not get
ahead in any kind of business even being
a lowly hot dog seller if you didn't
have some kind of Mafia protection
and in the Soviet Union and as it
morphed into Russia Mafia and government
became very blurred the lines became the
two became very blurred now pagodin
really made his fortune when he became
caterer to a number of Russian State
concerns including the Russian army he
was also the person who was catering to
a lot of Putin's State visits he's met
presidents he's met heads of state uh
there are even letters that were written
to him won by President Jacques Chiraq
who was entertained on pregosian's Boat
restaurant in Saint Petersburg but what
you have to understand in Russia is that
the links between crime and business
have have increased particularly when
you are that involved in providing
service this to the state and that close
to Vladimir Putin when you see that
close to Vladimir Putin can we quantify
that in what way did these two men have
anything other than you know a
professional relationship
but that is the big question and those
are the the murky areas the fact that
they come from Saint Petersburg that
they both participated in the period of
business opening up and business opening
up being supervised by crime the fact
that Vladimir Putin asked if guinea pig
origin to become the Kremlin Chef is
something very important to understand
because Putin has been very paranoid for
a very long time and putting his food
into somebody's hands is an enormous
vote of trust
so look from the mid 90s onwards we know
pregosian is in Putin's Circle and once
Putin becomes president in 2000 he
begins to get government contracts
including catering for the Russian army
and then at some point in the 2010s he
buys the Wagner group a mercenary
company and we're going to get more on
the group in just a second but this gets
us to the point doesn't it Samantha
where Evgeni pregosian first comes to
the Public's attention it was all the
way back at the end of 2022 with that
remarkable video which appeared to show
him recruiting for Wagner directly from
Russian prisons from Russian prisoners
now what did that tell us about
percussions relationship with Putin
well what was really interesting about
this video is that it actually appeared
because these kind of videos don't
appear unless they're allowed to appear
um until then again was actually denying
having any links to Wagner and all of a
sudden September late August early
September 2022 gaming pregosian comes
out publicly recruiting prisoners in in
in Russia's prisons for the so-called
special military operation
so a number of things are really
interesting here apart from the fact
that you're getting pregosian came out
of the cupboard
the fact that when you're in Russia the
prison service is under the control of
the internal Ministry it's it's a
government controlled operation and here
is this businessman
the head of a private Army being allowed
to go to prisons but not only being
allowed to go to prisons but offering
pardons to prisoners who would become
soldiers served for six months and if
they survived they will be pardoned now
under Russian law only the parliament or
the president that can actually pardon a
prisoner so
again we have this this legal vacuum
which it's raised a lot of questions as
to preggers power like how can this man
he's a businessman have the power to do
something which is the state's
prerogative
foreign
whose power grows alongside or perhaps
even because of that of Putin but it is
with Wagner that he has cemented his
influence
Joanna deos Pereira is senior research
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute Europe originally they were
offering different types of services and
they included not only Military Support
but also intelligence gathering training
in in several countries in Africa for
example also Logistics support for
Logistics actually most of the services
at the beginning were more related to
the ones that private security companies
provide we were talking about initially
about former highly trained Russian
military so at the beginning they are
standard even in terms of Recruitment
and and activities was very very
rigorous I would say and they were
paying rather well at the beginning at
the beginning they were rather small and
they became more evident when precaution
had this big window of opportunity
during the annexation of Crimea they
handle the situation quite
smoothly without bloodsheds and
basically the Kremlin saw on them a
potential useful tool for other
scenarios where Russia had interest I
mean I remember people talking about the
little green men those
soldiers that were operating in eastern
Ukraine Crimea without markings without
designation that would show you to which
army they belonged tell us a little bit
about that uh so before the invasion
some of them were
the world want to facilitate it the
entry of the Russian army so they became
known because they were not wearing
military insignia although their
uniforms were quite similar to the
Russian they were using Russian Weaponry
they were also training next to training
sites of official Russian military so
there was always this blurness between
what they did and what the Russian
military did so it was very difficult to
to understand who was who and and who
belonged to which organization during
this period
well who who now comprise at the Wagner
group mercenaries I mean you mentioned
earlier on that there was at least a
perception for a time that they had
worked quite effectively in in parts of
the world which suggest to me
well-trained you know former military
but at the moment Wagner does seem to be
heavily recruiting from you know from
the gulags from the prisons yes
from the gulags from
from they they recruited whoever said
yes or whoever wished to join their
ranks not even for a good salary because
this is no longer the case in terms of
what they have been tasked with on the
ground in Ukraine just describe to me
that the the type of operations that the
Russian military have been using these
mercenaries for
well we cannot say that the Russian
military are used mercenaries this would
be an acknowledgment that they recognize
them as partners on the ground I believe
that at this precise moment precaution
and Wagner are acting on a kind of Rogue
moves and they are not being officially
backed by the Russian military do we
have evidence of the Wagner group
committing war crimes in Ukraine wow
this is a very sensitive question there
are several indication
that they were present in Butcher and
that the same models operandi was used
in in Mora uh in Africa so I would say
yes Joanna just just on that point then
I mean France's designated Wagner a
terror group the British government
moving in that direction as well is is
there any chance though that you know
that designation by the United Kingdom
by France perhaps by the European Union
as a whole will have any effect on
Evgeni precaution honestly
it'd be pragmatical so it is a very
symbolic gesture if several countries or
even the European Union or the United
States take this huge step but in
Practical terms I would say that this
will affect the activities of Wagner
group very little especially because
they already proved that they can easily
reorganize themselves probably for
precaution it will be more difficult
because he has become so visible during
the war in Ukraine but Wagner group is
not only pregocian so Wagner group is an
octopus-like organization that is well
established in several countries in
Africa and that will survive after
precaution probably with another name
yevgeni pregosian is clearly a man of
significant means and influence but he
has on more than one occasion directly
criticized those at the top of the
Russian chain of command and that of
course comes very close to melanin Putin
himself and he's not a man known for his
tolerance of independent thought
Samantha well there's been actually an
escalation in pregosian's criticism of
the Russian leadership when he began to
criticize the ministry of defense and
certain individuals within the ministry
of Defense the defenseman is the Sergey
the head of general staff Valeria
garasimov a number of generals he's been
criticizing them openly using their
names for quite a few months right now
he's been criticizing the what he calls
the bureaucrats and the bureaucracy
sounds a bit like a breakfast sometimes
but I'd have to say so he's been upping
his criticism and the latest criticism
of the ministry of events saying
basically all these Dead Boys you see
behind me are dead because you the
ministry of defense did not give me
artillery shells but
just after the 9th of May so after
Putin's speech on the 9th of May morning
pregosian came out with two other videos
and these were really interesting
because he starts talking about a
grandfather he calls it the Russian iska
and he also uses the expression did now
the Russians and particularly when
Russians are being disrespectful towards
Putin they call him the diadushka the
dear the grandfather
was saying yes so um you know there's
this grandfather who thinks everything
is fine
um but you know he needs to be told that
everything isn't fine and what if this
grandfather was an absolute complete
idiot but he uses a word that's a lot
worse than idiot though we'll paraphrase
we'll paraphrase um but a pretty
horrible swear words and this has been
seen by a lot of the the Russian both
pro-war and anti-war bloggers the
telegram sphere a lot of questions have
been asked is he actually referring to
Putin here is this is this all about
then political positioning is is
pregosian perhaps you know setting
himself up as an alternative a future
alternative to put in the reason I say
that I mean it was only last month he
gave an interview to Russia's Federal
news agency in which the parallels
between the way in which he conducted
himself in that interview and the way in
which Vladimir Putin sits and holds
interviews and and public appearances
it's very distinctive it certainly felt
as if he was trying to ape it I mean
he's he's at least poking the beer a
little bit isn't he I think he is now
there are a lot of a lot of discussions
amongst the the Think Tank Community
amongst the Russia Specialists a lot of
people have different opinions on what
progression is doing some people will
say pregosian is not doing anything
without Putin's approval
I actually think that he is he is a
puppet who's now cutting his puppet
strings and trying to become the Puppet
Master himself he's behaving like a
populist politician he's positioning
himself is the only one who is telling
people the truth of what's happening on
the front lines
now whether or not he really is you know
lacking artillery shells is a question
and it could be a part of his show and
and this sort of absurd theater that he
seems to be creating but in terms of the
losses in terms of the dire situation
that the Russian troops in in terms of
the dire situation of the Russian army
he's the only person who's telling the
truth the man who's at the head of an
organization that people are calling
terrorists it's a very very bizarre
situation
so Joanna back to you on this if we
assume that bridge is telling the truth
about the lack of ammunition that he's
receiving but what does that say about
the relationship between the Russian
military and the Wagner group I mean
I've got two words for you cannon fodder
I mean does that adequately describe how
the Russian military is using the Wagner
group completely completely completely
and I think now it's more than than
Canon father I think he is an
embarrassment right now for for the
Kremlin he is not recognized amongst the
highest fears of the Kremlin and this is
is what in a certain way declare is
imminent downfall we are seeing a
desperate man that tries also uh
desperate moves to have the attention of
Vladimir Putin and trying also to be
recognized as someone who is doing
something patriotic for the Mother
Russia so he is the one staying he's the
one sacrificing their men in Bahamut and
this is far far away from from ending
because Vladimir Putin considers him as
a threat because he hasn't proved to be
of use what's the explanation
is because Vladimir Putin considers him
not the threat but a liability
I've said this many times before I do
not believe that brigadian wants a
Vladimir Putin's place for example what
he wants is recognition he wants
desperately to be recognized for the
sacrifices for the deaths of the the
young Russians that were killed in the
name of Russia but wearing the uniforms
of Wagner so Putin doesn't see him as a
threat but the huge liability because we
have seen how he behaves he doesn't play
by the official Russian Playbook
so Samantha how secure then do you think
pregosian's position is back in Russia
well I mean I suppose it depends on
whether he ever gets out of back mode
well you know there are people who say
he's probably safe for him backward than
in Russia these days there have been a
number of terrorist attacks but that's
what one could call them of far-right
military bloggers with links to Prego
gym there was a bomb that went off in
Saint Petersburg on the 2nd of April
that killed someone called vladolin
tatarski who was in a cafe owned by
pragosian there was another pro war
blogger called prelipian who was badly
injured when the car bomb went off a few
days ago in Russia the Russian
government has said oh this is Ukrainian
saboteurs terrorists special services
actually said each time I I don't I
don't think this is the ukrainians I
think this is some kind of intra-russian
warfare
[Music]
and whatever one thinks about whether
he's controlled by Putin or not pagodian
is definitely creating a rift between
the ministry of defense and his own
private Army and a rift between his
private armies and other private armies
so you really have got fertile ground
here for what I could only call Civil
War
my thanks to Joanna deos Pereira and
Samantha de bender and of course to you
for listening to the Sky News Daily with
me Neil Patterson this episode was
produced by Rosie Gillett with Alex Eden
our editor is Philly moment
[Music]